so we did a recent episode on tron for
visual effects artists react now
the original tron from 1982 is one of
the first movies to have heavy cg in it
other movies have had cg in them like
for example in the original star wars a
new hope there's the
blueprint of the death star they show in
a little tiny corner of a screen
whereas tron took it to a whole nother
level
this light cycle scene it's super super
basic it's super approachable now with
the tools we have
we were watching this and reveling at
all the immense work they had to do back
then
they didn't have you know ways to model
they didn't have ways to animate
get this they didn't have a way to get
the rendering from the computer to the
film
i mean they had to film off the screen
for some of this stuff it's pretty crazy
so we thought it'd be cool to go back
and recreate a scene from a major motion
picture in 1982
and we will do it in one day and we'll
make it exactly the same
now we're not gonna go to the point
where it's like we have to somehow print
each frame to film and then like do a 65
millimeter showing in an imax theater
two days from now to see if it turned
out we're not gonna do that part what we
are gonna do is we're gonna try to
recreate this scene
using some of the same techniques by
using modern tools to do so
to learn how they did it to respect how
they did it
and also to like totally dunk on them
with how good technology is these days
take that 40 year old movie swoosh what
is this caveman times
you know what the steaks aren't even
high enough yet let's do this i don't
know how to use blender yet
let's crank it up even further i'm gonna
go from not having used
this 3d program blender to rendering a
scene
in one afternoon i have faith in nico if
you know any 3d software it's pretty
easy to switch between them so
i'd like to think so so when the light
cycles appear here they appear to have
wireframes but
i gotta assume and this is something
they said that this is hand painted
and a lot of the 3d stuff and 3d stuff
in this movie it's just people using
airbrushing to make it look like a 3d
model
yeah it totally is you can see on the
wheel on the rim of the wheel right
there the lines are completely straight
so that grid appears and then we finally
see the light cycle now i think we
should start from this frame where the
light cycles take off as our first
shot we'll skip the stuff with the
actors things like that we're just
focusing the cg
so the first thing that stands out to me
all the motorcycles are exactly the same
model with just a color shift also
supposedly all of this is
modeled with primitives a primitive is
just a basic shape like a sphere or a
cube or a taurus
i mean at least i can see some pretty
clear primitives here we have a sphere
and we have like a cutout which is
probably just another sphere cutting
that out
we have another tinier sphere in the
inside there's a monkey primitive in
blender well there's a t-box primitive
in 3ds max the hell is that
the teapot was one of the first real
world objects to have all of its
coordinates
written out by hand and then put into a
computer for the very first object to be
brought into a computer was a hand
they took a model of a hand and then
plotted out where all the points were
and they made a rendering of it here it
is
the first ever 3d model that looks
pretty good it looks really good
i can model that in an hour anyways oh
they took off okay
now we have to think about these trails
so there's a gradient here
and the trail kind of curves and you
know what's weird so i look at it right
here where it starts
you can see the trail kind of appearing
i'm led to believe that the trail
is already there and it's just being
revealed from like a bully it's two
objects right you can see the little
gradient and where it cuts off
and that is just attached to the bike
itself and then the trail
seems like a separate object
if you look closely at this frame side
now just out of revelation if those
trails were attached to the motorcycle
the motorcycles
tilted when they turned the trail would
tilt too and that's probably why the
motorcycles don't tilt because later on
when the motorcycles escape they do in
fact tilt so they
clearly knew to animate them like that
but the trails probably prevented them
from doing so
so so far i haven't seen any shots that
are particularly hard it's it's quite a
few shots
so this is all standard animation camera
angles there's no motion blur there's no
camera shake really
it looks like you could literally
keyframe it by hand or use a spline
follow for the animation which is not
how they did it if you want to do it
like they did it would make we'd save a
file for each frame oh my god that
sounds awful
up to where
what is that we're working on unit three
so that way we can actually have a
studio floor for filming
and another space for computers where it
can be quiet and we can focus on our
work
like this all day yesterday
and i'll probably like that all day
tomorrow too
all right so here's the last thing
that's unique about
this scene that we're gonna do i think
we're gonna end it is when the guy
crashes into the wall and puts a hole in
the wall
boom so looking at this frame by frame
it looks pretty straightforward
we have a spiky 3d model that just
scales up and
disappears we have rings that just scale
up and then disappear
the motorcycle is literally split into
all of its primitive shapes
and they don't even rotate they just fly
out and so how do you think they did
that do you think it's just a bunch of
primitives
definitely just stacked primitives so
here's what we have to do to make this
shot we have to make the objects we have
to make the
light cycles and to make the trails
which make the environment so that's
basically the grid ground
and the background wall we'll deal with
the little extra special bits when we
get there
then we have to animate it and then we
have to render it let's make it
we have to make it look like this so
it's a very simple rendering it should
be straightforward to do but
at this point it's almost hard to go
back and like find the old style
rendering systems
honestly that might be the most
challenging part of this is making it
look
like it did in this because now we have
all these fancy renderers that simulate
light and reflections and everything and
we gotta
dumb it down to have it be just shapes
and colors and gradients and that's it
and then don't forget peter's gonna
teach me how to do all this in blender
at the same time
corridor is officially switching to
blender no we love cinema 4d
we love 740. and octane render
sam and and ren and nico told me in
private
that's not true right now that's fine
google it i will give you a concession a
little bit i did say in private off
camera
that i should probably learn blender and
that it has a lot of great features
did i say it was better never said that
so i guess we'll fire up blender and
won't you just show me how to do it
all right computer
all right peter we want to make a light
cycle we're going to make it with
primitives i have no idea how to use
blender
all right let's do it so the first thing
you want to do to bring any objects into
blender any primitive or basically any
element you want to bring into blender
you do shift a
that brings up a little menu for you go
through here got cameras
got curves you got force fields go up to
mesh and what kind of primitive would
you like to add
well the front tire on the bicycle looks
like it was a sphere without a spirit
cut out of it
yeah this is i mean this is looking just
like 3ds max cinema 4d it's just
the way you create an object is
different now every time you create
primitive you also create a soul so you
have to have a container
where all the souls go and you don't
have to worry about them
do you have that container all set in
this computer yeah um i installed the
plugin so we should be good to go okay
great
well what would you like to do next well
so you know the way they
operated is they had the primitives and
they would boolean them with other
primitives so let's create a second
sphere
and show me how you bully in one from
the other all right let's do it you keep
saying this
and i assume you're not making a soup
broth
what does that mean yeah that's right so
buoy eating
is it's a mathematical term but in this
case we're using it for
addition or subtraction uh with objects
we want to have a sphere and we want to
cut a hole out of that sphere
using another sphere as the object that
makes the cutting
wait were those numbers that were
changing i saw a bunch of numbers
changing while you moved it around
these numbers up here i'm guessing are
the numbers they had to punch in
every single frame for the old run your
three rotation
numbers and your three axes in terms of
your position and to write those down
frame by frame for every object if they
want to animate something totally and
you can actually
bring those values up here you can see
this is how they are like exactly what
they would be looking at
so we got two objects intersecting with
each other yeah two balls
we add modifier they lane object eye
dropper
and i dropped this little sphere right
here you can see nothing happened
nothing
happened but actually something did
happen below the surface if we go to
wireframe view
and uh toggle this on and off so then we
can delete that sphere and boom we got a
little hole cut out of this sphere
yeah so it's just a regular sphere oh
you're right with a sphere bleed out of
it
it looks like i'm just another boolean
sphere inside of there to give you the
black shape so peter's not trying to
teach me how to use blender he's trying
to teach me how to do 80s vfx inside
blender
so knowing primitives and knowing
booleans that's technically all
we should need to make this motorcycle
would you like me to
you know what peter i feel like i think
you're ready
you want me to take over all right time
to add a middle sphere i hit
shift a to go back to the 80s and then i
create a sphere in the 80s
he's learning so good he's doing so
good and i want to be scooted outwards
just a little bit
hey is this a light side nico is that
tron not only is this tron this is also
a new industrial design for a speaker
so all speaker companies can now pay me
for the rights to use the shape
dang niko's getting the hang of this
real quick i'm impressed
so these guys have finished recreating
tron
and it wasn't as easy as they thought it
was gonna be
what was the biggest challenge trying to
concentrate this loud work environment
peter and i started working on the shots
yesterday like got the motorcycles built
and kind of built the world the looks
kind of fallen into place
it's like okay it's time to start
animating this will be easy this will be
easy it'll take no time at all
uh yes so today we're going to present
to you the light cycle sequence
remastered and reapproached in modern
times took many people
many many days of time peter and i went
out and just did it in one day
okay but it should be stated that niko
learned blender for this video like
start to finish
which is really impressive the shots
you're gonna see here the three shots i
did are my first
three renders i've ever done in blender
i saw two shots
and i didn't realize that they were not
the original tron shots
oh thank you
[Music]
so i think you're trying to bamboozle me
right now
this is the original tron we're watching
the original tron first everybody has a
point of reference before
we show them our version you're not
being ghastly you're not
wait a second wait a second you didn't
see anything i just saw a little
glitch what did you see i know what i
saw i just saw one of the background
shapes
bleed through into the foreground i did
too wait but this is the original
because there's the insert of the tron
man
the tron man's in there all right you
guys got us
we tricked you that was that was our
version that we watched first
[Music]
watching
bran and nick figured it out like three
shots in
it was not very obvious like so now i
don't really have context for what
you have recreated now i actually
legitimately do need to see the original
[Music]
versions
[Music]
that explosion looks really solid dude
like
you matched the aesthetic so this is
where it's most obvious
by like a huge margin that they're not
the same shots because they don't line
up at
all and yet if you're just to look at
them one after another you wouldn't be
able to tell
it's one thing to just animate some
stuff driving it around in a grid it's
another thing to try to make it
look like somebody's work from 40 years
ago yeah i mean those turns
were just ridiculous nice we could have
just had it animated along the path
but they didn't have that technology
back in the day but yeah we were
guessing
that for the corners they just had two
separate bike models and two separate
trail models they were just
bullying out of existence one motorcycle
and
leaning into existence another one at
least it makes me really appreciate
just the amount of like foresight and
planning and like knowing that you sit
down and do this math it's like it
should work out it's kind of like the
same thing as
shooting a rocket into this like hitting
the moon it's like i did the math
it should work if any of the original
tron artists are watching this video
we'd love to have you
break down how you actually approach
this that'd be super cool hit us up
please
yeah what if he went through and just
updated all the textures and threw in a
modern rendering engine so it's the
exact same
shot as the original tron but looks more
modern
yeah i mean we could totally do that we
would literally just be like pressing
buttons and changing sliders and stuff
like that to just
up it to the next level
[Music]
uh well let us know what you think of
our tron sequence did it match the
original was it a complete
disrespect to the artists we just spit
on their work and just
grind our heel into it this ended up
being really fun i think it'd be really
cool to do this again with other famous
vfx shots they have to be achievable so
i could just go and redo the avengers
one take i kind of feel like we could do
the matrix
bullet dodge that would be a fun one
it's one thing to react to it's another
thing to live it
whoa i hope you learned something today
hope you enjoyed the video
yeah that's it consider going to our
website corridor digital.com
if you enjoyed watching us retrace the
footsteps of early cgi pioneers and you
might enjoy the upcoming functional
filmmaking series we've taken all the
crazy knowledge we've gained from the 10
years of making videos on youtube and we
packed them into this series exclusive
for corridor digital.com subscribers
head on over if you want to take part in
that and see the other crazy shows that
have been greenlit as well
thanks for watching i'll see you in the
next one